You guys probably don't need ME to tell you
that sometimes, swearing just feels f*cking
awesome.
I mean fricking.
We can saying fricking, right?
Hey folks, Laci Green here for DNews.
I grew up in a household where swearing was
a biiiiiig nono.
I remember once my dad was driving me to school
and I accidentally said "what the fuck?" out
loud while reading a text.
Bad times, my friends.
Never forget.
I have often asked myself: what's so bad about
cursing anyway?
They're just....words.
What's interesting is that what counts as
a vulgarity varies by culture -- but every
language in the world has swear words.
It also depends on the time period.
For example, in the 1700s, "quim" had an effect
quite like today's "c-word".
And while some curse words live long lives,
they may lose or gain offensiveness over time.
Like "bastard", which was considered MUCH
more offensive in the 1800s than it is today.
Dr. Melissa Mohr, author of "Holy Shit: A
Brief History of Swearing", writes that throughout
history, the general trend is that what counts
as a vulgarity depends on what the society
believes is taboo, most scary, or most interesting.
Under this banner comes more expansions like
bodily functions and sexual or racial epithets.
In this sense, curse words hold a unique cultural
power to mark what is "good" and "bad".
That in mind, scientists have found that the
act of cursing provides people with a number
of benefits.
The main one being pain relief.
Scientists at Keele University in the UK have
found that, particularly for those who don't
swear often, letting your mouth run wild can
help when you're in pain.
For the study, patients put their hands in
an ice cold bucket of water and were told
to hold it there as long as possible.
For the group that was allowed to swear during
the experiment, they lasted, on average, about
31 seconds longer than the non-swearing group.
They believe that swearing activates the brain's
endogenous opioid centers -- which results
in a sensation similar to morphine.
For those who curse a lot, they have built
up a tolerance, and need more extreme profanities
to elicit the same effect.
It's kind of like a drug in your brain.
Another widespread benefit of cursing is more
psychological, it provides us with a way to
let it all out and get back at people without
physically harming them.
Although, that doesn't necessarily mean that
we aren't harming someone at all by using
words instead of physical violence.
After all, we know that words can drive someone
to the edge -- the most extreme effects of
verbal abuse being self-harm or even suicide.
Swearing can also help us feel like we have
more power and control over a situation than
we may actually have.
As for those non-angry swears, a recent paper
in the American Journal of Psychology notes
that swearing can encourage social bonding
through humor or a shared sense of belonging.
So folks, tell me: do you swear?
Do you see any benefits or problems with it?
Tell me what you think down below and we'll
be back later with more f*cking updates.